right now it's all about making it easy
[Music]
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time we have
effectively and the one thing that can
really help you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs
is so versatile it can be used to make a
dozen amazing dishes one of my favorites
is meatballs in fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
lifesaver
it means you never have to compromise on
flavor these meatballs are delicious
but more portly they free so well first
off get your pan on and start sweating
off your onions and your garlic this
recipe involves making the meatballs in
a classic way but the exciting part it's
actually cook them in coconut milk I
think it's a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft rich sumptuous
meatball chop the only nice and finely
even those slices very close together
close to the slices the finer the end
Pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop what the onions nice and
fine because I want some finesse to
these meatballs my secret of a really
good meatball is the texture getting
that balance right between the minced
beef the bread crumbs the milk and the
seasoning a couple cloves of garlic
slice the garlic
really nice and thinly nice pan nice and
hot a tablespoon of olive oil quite
generous available I'm using garlic in
with such a salt and pepper
[Music]
with your mints open it up a little bit
and sort of pad it out salt and pepper
for me a good meatball is all about the
softness the texture of that rich beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color on the outside but
you want it nice and soft and sort of
rich in the center mix that in
beautifully and then place it back out
again I got some really nice dried chili
flakes on the season onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in cook that
out for two minutes oonh add some milk
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
take four tablespoons of milk that makes
a sort of nice slightly doughy texture
but it lightens the texture of the
meatball place that then add your onions
your garlic and your chili in there as
well
nice get your hands in there start
mixing them if you've got the right
amount of milk and bread crumbs
it doesn't mean binding with an egg
don't make them too small problem with
making them too small is the fact that
they dry out quickly just size or golf
ball it'll be bigger nice doing a really
nice Thai squeeze and stops it from
breaking out
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipeout then wash out that pan
we've got that flavor from the onions
and the garlic in the bottom get that
pan nice and hot touch of olive oil in
there
place them the top of your pan nice and
gently set them in the oil pallet knife
and go underneath them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're gonna add
some heat coriander seeds a spicy
peppery was to give a really nice flavor
to the coconut milk in next some
cardamom seeds three or four onto the
board knife on and a little touch of
turmeric into the center of the pan
I'll give it really nice spicy flavor a
little pinch cinnamon all the time
you're doing this those meatballs are
just getting tastier and taste yeah a
couple of dried chilies let them infuse
in their oil and then some lemongrass
just take the back of your knife and
sort of beat it down that starts to
release all that lovely sort of
fragrance now someone's just let off the
most amazing fragrant air freshener in
the lemongrass
and finally some fresh ginger just peel
this slice nice and thinly time now
tell them over and let the other half a
wonderful flavor
chicken stock in
bring the stock up the boil turn the gas
up and then add the coconut milk and on
the coconut milk just sitting underneath
the top of a meatball coconut milk in
and that sort of gives it that creamy
richness but it's not heavy
it's a fragrant light richness before we
start simmering check the seasoning a
nice soft texture of the meatball but
that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's gonna cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
and simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger this should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gasps off I'm gonna finish it off with
something light and fresh zest of lime
but I want the zest on top of the
meatball so I'll cut through that
richness and then finally squeeze fresh
lime and that just gives it that nice
zesty amazing taste stirring the juice
mmm got that kick and then a vibrant
taste now exciting part when you come to
serve it be generous with that coconut
broth tilt the pan get good couple of
ladles of the broth in mmm meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very delicious way of
eating a old-fashioned meatball and
bringing it into the 21st century and
they're just as good to cook from frozen
as well
[Music]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself there are
three more recipes all based on where
delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
first up beef meatballs without a kitty
kale and pine nuts
at meatballs to hot oil and brown
meanwhile cook autocad eat pasta then
add chopped garlic to the meatballs and
shredded kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which cooks in
minutes cabbage is a great alternative
if you can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam through
when the passwords cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs
season then finish with sweet buttery
pine nuts and grated fresh Parmesan
cheese meatballs with honour Ketty
kale and pine nuts from meatballs to
meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is please
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa top a
lightly toasted roll with pan-fried
meatballs then tear off chunks of creamy
buffalo mozzarella pile it on and melt
it under the grill but a tangy salsa
slice sweet red onion then have juicy
diced tomatoes and roughly chopped fresh
coriander
seasons and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich
to die for my final super easy meatball
recipe is fiery meatball soup
[Music]
by chopped onion and finely sliced
garlic in hot olive oil add cumin seeds
for warmth and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out once the meatballs
are browned add hot chili paste for a
spicy kick tin tomatoes dried oregano
and a liter of beef stock
[Music]
then simmer next add sweet corn and
chopped cause yes
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers
chopped fresh coriander and crushed
tortilla chips
a one-pot meatball wonder that really
packs a punch
firing meatball soup one versatile
meatball recipe for deliciously
different dishes food that's certain to
make your life in the kitchen easier and
stress-free amazing whether you're
making great food to fries or to take
straight to a table you need to know how
to shop for the best ingredients next up
my shopping guide to oils
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter the
taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for sunflower oil is a good
value all-rounder nice and light for
frying bacon in dressings and spicy
dishes ground nuts or peanut oil is
great for cooking on high heat as it
gets really hot without burning sesame
oil a flavor some sweet and nutty oil
perfect sprinkled over Asian dishes
before serving rapeseed oil is a
healthier choice for using in salads
I love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
is brilliant for salad dressings and it
gives cakes a distinctive flavor
but the oil I used most in my cooking is
olive oil
[Music]
to find some of the best olive oils sold
in Britain you have to go to one of the
most unlikely places an electrical shop
in London's East End
[Music]
turkish born mehmet murat has olive oil
in his blood my family's produced this
olive oil for centuries
what he doesn't know about it isn't
worth knowing the very best extra-virgin
olive oil is first cold-pressed it's
actually pressed by stone and then it's
put for a centrifugal spinner which
spins out all the bitter waters and then
you've got your pure olive oil
cold-pressed olive oil and you've got to
taste it to believe it for a little
sample slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth of
it and then swallow it'll go down like
fruit juice and it will leave no greasy
nasur oiliness in your mouth whatsoever
absolutely sensational beautiful my
favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room-temperature
rub some wild oregano into it and get
some fresh crusty bread and just dip it
it's food on its own don't leave
anything else
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food you don't
need to spend a fortune on masses of
kitchen equipment here are three more
kitchen essentials whisk spoon and
spatula these three items are so cheap
yet they are so important to great home
cooking a whisk the same has more
control when you've got something
whisking in your hand you can gauge it
so much better than canapes on an
electric mixer the bigger the balloon on
your hand whisk the faster will whip as
it draws in more air wooden spoons don't
scratch pans and should be washed by
hand spatulas are indispensable for
baking or mixing make sure it's
heat-resistant so it doesn't melt but
more importantly phenomenal for making
omelets great with scrambled eggs and
you waste nothing to the Spanish that
almost cleans the bowl instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro and you'll
need all three for my next recipe my
take on classic chocolate brownies
guarantee to put a smart on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
Blondie's stock up on these delicious
Blondie's they'll keep for up to a week
and it's a great way of getting ahead if
you're expecting guests round first off
melt the butter for the mixture we've
had hundreds and hundreds of brownies
the sort of white chocolate version ie
Blondie's are amazing a little bit more
subtle keep a little knob of butter for
the end just to grease your baking tray
tell the guests down and gently melt
that butter caster sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk it
sort of makes the mixture little bit
lighter it slightly fluffy off with the
gas a pinch of salt in the sugar then
make a little well in the middle that's
on a whisk you see so what do you got
nice and blunt like give that a really
good mix and a secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
and nice and smooth a teaspoon of
vanilla extract in next lightly whisk in
two whole eggs
she's giving a little beat this is such
a delicious recipe yes so simple
whisking the eggs looking for that nice
sort of rich taste just smooth paste you
can see why we call these blond this
beautiful next teaspoon of baking powder
baking powder in and half a teaspoon of
baking soda that Harriet's the mixture
and gives it that little tartness you'll
see this sort of rise instantly the
minute they hit the oven and then your
flour whisk with one hand I'm just
slowly at half the flour first get that
all mixed up make sure that mixture is
really nice and smooth check it
occasionally
no lumps are flowering and you'll feel
it's sort of almost they're nice and
firm and that's why it's so important to
add the flour in stages it stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the whisk beautiful
changeover from a whisk to a spoon next
awesome texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondest dried
cranberries they bake beautifully but it
gives the blondie now really nice sort
of chewy sweetness in the center next my
white chocolate
I'm gonna grate it go chop it up just
slice it
my little bits of shrapnel I want the
chocolate my little matchsticks
dottie around chocolate in lovely fold
that in on a nice even distribution of
those wonderful dried cranberries don't
over mix it I want to break up that
chocolate and I see even mix of
cranberries and chocolate you can see
the chocolate there'll be parts of the
chocolate in the oven that are actually
melt I'll be like little pools of white
melted shot in the center now a baking
tray small little knob of butter and the
greased baking tray and liner some
greaseproof paper and just over extend
it shiny side out dull side hits the
bottom of the tray in crease proof
allows me to maximise on the white
chocolate inside the mix no grease proof
paper the chocolate come out and stick
to the tray so the paper is just a
really nice insurance policy secondly
what that rise and that sort of
Christmas now with the mix get your
spatula go all the way around and all
see anything left in that ball position
the ball over your tray no I said
carefully allow me don't leave that
slice in the bowl nobody's licking that
one and then just take the back of a
spatula go into the corners push and
come back into the middle turn the tray
around then it worked to your advantage
trying to get it evenly positioned in
the tray
if it goes in even it cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top the
blondie with the back of the spatula and
then into the oven it's gonna rise nice
and crisp on a soft gooeyness in the
center
make your Blondie's at 180 degrees for
35 to 40 minutes that smells incredible
for that crisp edge on the outside and
that sort of soft gooey center leave
that to cool down and it's gonna sort of
firm up from wrinkled but it'll stay
nice and gooey in the center once it's
cooled down take it out and start
slicing mouth-watering blonde is a
fantastic easy treat to have on hand for
yourself or to share
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips to make your life easier make sure
you make the most of your freezer my tip
for amazing tuna carpaccio is to freeze
it first and it will slice beautifully
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine and freezer bags or ice
cube trays is great in stocks and
sources when you freeze soups or stews
in tubs the tip is not to overfill them
leave room to expand in the container a
great tip for a cheese homemade ice
cream buy a high-quality vanilla ice
cream and making your own buy makes an
embarrassed chocolate or my favorite rum
and boozy raisins
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes
they won't water down your drink and
they'll also add flavor
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stake your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking